It doesn’t feel quite real to say this
but… mission accomplished. I did it,
I actually made it through. My extraction is
currently en route, and once they’re here, I’ll
be heading back to the SCP Foundation. It doesn’t
feel like a hundred days since this all started,
if anything it feels like a lot longer. But
it’s done now, the mission is finally over – and
now the real work begins. I’ll be taken in for
debriefing when I arrive, so I’d better get my
story straight before that transport gets here.
Here’s how I Survived 100 Days Infiltrating
the Chaos Insurgency.
It started with a message;
a direct request passed down straight to me from
the O5 Council themselves. I was shocked initially
to receive any communication from them; the
Council were hardly hands-on bosses, preferring
to co-ordinate the Foundation from a station far,
far above mine. I was part of a Mobile Task Force,
used to being out in the field, so when I got the
message – saying the Council wanted to talk to
me – I wasn’t quite sure what to make of it.
I went through various different states of
reaction in my head, first being honored that
they had singled me out. That then turned into
worry – had I done something wrong, or was this
some kind of dismissal from the Foundation? Was
it a performance review? When it finally came
time for me to stand before the O5 Council,
the last thing that I was expecting
to hear was that they had selected me
specially for a dangerous undercover assignment.
Of course, I had heard of the Chaos Insurgency
before. Although I was yet to actually
encounter them in the field, the MTFs
were all instructed to keep up to date on who the
Foundation’s enemies were. As a Group of Interest,
it wasn’t hard to see why they were such a
threat. A heavily armed, clandestine organization
with goals of weaponizing SCPs and achieving
world domination: they sounded like lunatics,
but dangerous lunatics all the same.
That was the first step in my mission:
know your enemy. I was instructed to
familiarise myself with the Chaos Insurgency,
to understand them inside and out. While the MTF
agent in me wanted to just get boots to ground
and start the real work, this operation needed a
different approach. And so, I hit the books; or,
to put it more accurately, I began scouring the
SCP Foundation’s database for any and all intel on
the Insurgency. All I could do was sit and read.
Within forty-eight hours of being given my
assignment, I felt like I knew everything
about the Chaos Insurgency back to front,
sideways, upside down, and pretty
much any and every way possible. So,
imagine how disheartened I felt when I reported my
research to the O5 Council, only to be told that
I hadn’t done enough. Hardly the best feeling,
I won’t deny it stung to hear that my day of
research wasn’t adequate prep for my assignment.
But the Council did have an important point:
this was a covert, deep-cover infiltration into
one of the most dangerous groups that opposed
the Foundation. Purely memorizing all manner of
facts and figures about the Insurgency, learning
of all their tactical capabilities, reading up on
the various rumors about how they were founded;
all that was just knowledge. If I wanted to pass
myself off as a part of the Chaos Insurgency
and avoid detection, knowing wasn’t
enough. I had to think like one of them.
The timeline of the mission began to accelerate
rapidly. I would have to train myself to believe
the Insurgency’s core beliefs as I went along;
events weren’t going to wait for me to ne ready.
The Council informed me that they were aware of
a double agent working for the Chaos Insurgency
from within the SCP Foundation itself.
Obviously, I had heard rumors that there
were operatives embedded within the ranks of
the Foundation, but what was more surprising
was that the O5 Council seemed to already know
who these agents were. I had always assumed
that these Insurgents kept their identities
a secret, so to hearing that a particular
researcher – Doctor Parsons – was a known Chaos
Insurgency conspirator and still had a job at
the Foundation was both startling and worrying.
But he provided me a way in, and I assumed that’s
why the O5 Council allowed the Insurgency’s
double agents to remain as ‘undetected’ as they
thought they were. It meant they could be used as
tools for the Foundation’s benefit to get at the
Insurgency – they were double agents, after all.
Doctor Parsons was due to be at the same
Foundation site I was stationed at for only
a few days. The upside of working directly
on the orders of the Council meant that
they had the administerial reach to pull
all the necessary strings to get this
duplicitous double agent in the right
place for me to intercept him, but not for long.
The window of opportunity was only a small one,
I had a short time to get close enough to Parsons
and get him to put me in contact with his friends
at the Chaos Insurgency. Of course, I had to
be tactful about it. If I came on too strong,
there was a strong chance the double agent would
easily detect that something was off and that his
cover had been blown. So, the plan was simple:
strike up a conversation with the spy, in a way
that wouldn’t arouse suspicion and would compel
him to assist my joining the Chaos Insurgency.
Actually, ‘simple’ might not
have been the right word.
The day of my confrontation with Parsons
I was uncontrollably nervous. I could feel
myself shaking and silently hoped that it wasn’t
noticeable to anyone looking at me. The mess hall,
was decided as the best place I could drum
up some kind of conversation with him. As I
picked up my food tray, I spotted the doctor
taking a seat in a far corner. Cautiously,
I approached and asked if I could join him.
In the back of my head, I kept reminding
myself I had to play it casual. If I went in
immediately with claiming I felt the Foundation
should be run differently, then Parsons would
smell the deception, and the whole mission
would come apart. So instead, I started small.
We drummed up a conversation about the quality
of the food the Foundation catering team had
given us – or rather, the lack of quality.
Then we chatted about containment
procedures, and various anomalies
that we had each encountered in our different
jobs. Lunch was wrapping up, we’d both finished
our food and I knew my window was about to
close. And so, I threw in to conversation:
“You ever get sick of the way they do things?”
The entire next day, I was on edge, worried
that I’d thrown my assignment and alerted
Parsons that the Foundation was aware of
his ties to the Insurgency. I didn’t leave
the Task Force barracks, confining myself to
my quarters. If I left, there was always a
slim chance of running into Doctor Parsons,
or that the Council would call me in to
reprimand how I handled first contact.
To my surprise, my paranoid thoughts were broken
by a direct message from Parsons. He mentioned
being intrigued by some of our conversation the
previous day, and being disappointed I hadn’t
been in the mess hall this lunchtime to continue
discussing certain aspects. It felt weirdly nice
being friendly, only to then remember the man
was a double agent for the Chaos Insurgency.
His message went on to suggest we should meet
in private in his office. And that’s when the
tension really hit me. Either he wanted me dead
with no witnesses, or he had bought my line
about disagreeing with the Foundation’s methods.
I arrived at Parsons’ office at the agreed time,
only to be welcomed warmly by the
doctor. It was instantly disarming,
and intentionally so. I tried not to fall for
it, just in case he knew what I was really up
to. But at the same time, I couldn’t let it show.
Doctor Parsons seemed to pick up our discussion
from the other day, immediately talking
about how the SCP Foundation would be
better off putting anomalies to use rather
than keeping them contained. I was surprised
how brazen he was being, but then again,
the Council knew he was a mole, maybe they
had bugged his office, and he hadn’t realized.
Nodding along, pretending to agree with what the
doctor was saying, the conversation quickly
progressed. I told Parsons I felt the same,
and it was frustrating to me as an MTF agent,
seeing so many co-workers die in containment
breaches against SCPs. That was the moment he
mentioned he had ‘some friends I should meet.’
The following night, they came for me while I
slept in the barracks. I had no idea who had
drugged me, although I suspected it was Doctor
Parsons. He wasn’t there when I woke up though,
in fact, I couldn’t really tell who was
at first. The combination of the bag over
my face and my head still reeling from
whatever had knocked me out saw to that.
Wherever I was, I didn’t get to see it.
There were figures near me, at least two,
that much I could make out. Especially when the
interrogation started. They were Chaos Insurgency;
their line of questioning told me that. Between
punches and tasing, their questions ranged from
what I was really up to, to whether the Foundation
had sent me to infiltrate their organization.
They’d anticipated the Council would use their
own tactics against them, but every time,
no matter how much pain they inflicted, I
denied it. I wasn’t a mole, I told them over
and over again: I believed what they believed.
After over a week of torture, the bag came off,
and I was greeted by the sight of my captors in
Chaos Insurgency tactical gear. They informed
me that I had passed the initial phase
of their recruitment process, and after
suffering so much, that should have come as
a relief. My mission to infiltrate them was
progressing, but their interrogation had
left me exhausted and in intense pain.
The pair of Insurgents made it very clear that
I wasn’t one of them though, not yet. In order
to fully join their ranks, they wanted to
send me on an operation with one of their
armed detachments. If I complied with orders, and
made a deliberate act against the SCP Foundation,
that would tell them that I was ready to become
part of the Chaos Insurgency. If I refused,
or the mission was deemed to be a failure,
it would mean an on-the-spot execution.
Hiding my reluctance, knowing I wouldn’t be
able to forewarn the Foundation, I agreed.
I spent the next several days with a new group
of Insurgency operatives. None of them gave me
their names, nor any actionable intel I could
pass on to the Council. I just had to refer
to them by their various Gamma and Beta class
numbers, their ranks within the Chaos Insurgency.
The mission was an extraction; as part of their
efforts to utilize anomalies, the Insurgency would
often launch violent raids on the Foundation to
capture SCPs. Their target this time was SCP-2800,
the Cactusman. He was mostly harmless save for his
spines, but the group’s leaders, Delta Command,
wanted to force SCP-2800 to join their ranks.
I had to treat it like any other operation with
my MTF, trying to force myself to forget that I
was on the wrong side as we broke into the Site
containing SCP-2800. He didn’t want to leave,
but I hoped that the Foundation would eventually
launch a counter mission to rescue him. All
that mattered for now was making the Insurgency
see that I could be helpful, and useful to them.
Sure enough, the Foundation did recover SCP-2800.
And by the time they did, the Chaos Insurgency
had already welcomed me into their ranks. I’d
proven myself and that I shared their beliefs in
utilizing the anomalous to realize their goals.
During the mission, I had made a point of showing
my experience and skills as an MTF operative,
hoping that would impress them. It seemed to
have done the trick, as I was made a member
of Beta Class, still under the command of
Gamma and the Delta Command above them.
But it was a start, at least, not as low
in the chain as the Alpha Class were. They
were Insurgency recruits with no experience
dealing with anomalies, and who only joined
to escape their miserable lives. Delta
Command considered Alpha Class expendable,
as if they were little more than just cannon
fodder. I couldn’t help but feel bad for them,
especially when I realized that the Foundation
treated their D Class exactly the same.
Even the MTFs were mostly foot soldiers to them…
Now established within the Insurgency’s ranks,
I spent the next two weeks finding out everything
I could about their operations and reporting back
to the O5 Council through a secure, encrypted
channel. Part of my infiltration mission was
to see if I could locate the Engine, a mysterious
anomalous artifact that had apparently influenced
the earliest members – now Delta Command – to
form the Chaos Insurgency in the first place.
There was no sign of the Engine anywhere in
the compound I was stationed at. Then again,
its location was likely a closely guarded
secret. I did, however, encounter one of the
anomalies within the Insurgency’s possession. It
was SCP-1316, what appeared to be an ordinary and
harmless kitten named Lucy. But in actuality,
SCP-1316 was an intelligent and sophisticated
listening device used to spy on the Foundation
and report back to the Insurgency; I made sure
to warn the Council the moment I found out,
letting them know it wasn’t just double agents
being used to report on Foundation activity.
Just as things were starting to form a regular
pattern, things seemed to start going south. A
few of my ‘fellow’ Insurgents seemed to mention
things in conversation that made me start to feel
paranoid. They weren’t directly referencing me,
but they talked openly about what they’d do if
they found out the Foundation had tried to spy
on the Insurgency; and none of it was pleasant.
I spent the rest of the day wracked with worry.
There was no way they could have known I was
communicating with the O5 Council, or that
the only reason I was there had been to gather
intelligence on the Chaos Insurgency. It could
have just been what people talked about here,
although I couldn’t shake my concern that maybe my
cover had been blown, that this was their subtle
way of telling me the Insurgency was onto me.
The worrying left me no choice, and I raised my
concerns with the Council the first chance I got.
Unfortunately, the response I received the
following day did little to subdue my worries.
The O5 Council contacted me, reminding me of the
importance of my mission. I was to infiltrate and
report back to them, find the Engine or at least
its location. There was an extraction planned,
arriving in secret in a month’s time. That
was my time limit, and a warning came with it:
“If you can’t complete this assignment, then
don’t bother returning to the Foundation,”
the Council told me. “If you are unsuccessful
in carrying out your objectives, it will be
taken as an act of sedition. We will consider
you an active member of the Chaos Insurgency,
and thus a threat to the Foundation.”
I was furious, not to mention scared
out of my mind. The Council was willing to
turn their backs on me if I couldn’t deliver,
and if the Insurgency found out they had
a mole in their ranks, then it sounded
like they were ready to kill me on the spot.
The Insurgency were gearing up for another
mission, this time a more aggressive attack on the
Foundation as opposed to the stealthier extraction
that I’d previously been on. Surprisingly, that
put me more at ease; sure, it’d be dangerous,
but this was what I was good at. In the
field intensity, combating anomalies. I
could use this as an opportunity to regain some
footing, remind the Chaos Insurgency what made
me useful to them… or so I thought.
The mission was to capture SCP-682,
and fit it with a piece of technology
the Insurgency had tested on SCP-2394,
a form of sapient tree frog. Their plan was the
device would enable them to control the Hard to
Destroy Reptile, meaning the Insurgency would have
an unstoppable, adaptable killing machine in their
arsenal. The attack on the Foundation site was a
bloodbath, MTFs beset the Insurgents on all sides.
And as for 682… well, it wasn’t exactly known
for coming quietly without putting up a fight.
Returning from the field, after only a few days,
I was confronted by a higher-up, a member of
Gamma Class that oversaw the Insurgency’s
operations. He told me that there had been
numerous reports from other operatives, that they
hadn’t seen me killing or even injuring Foundation
personnel during the failed extraction of SCP-682.
It was true, I was still loyal to the Foundation,
after all. The people working there were still
my co-workers, even if I was pretending to be an
Insurgent. I’d deliberately missed shots, still
using my weapon in the firefights with MTFs, but
without causing them harm. I’d hoped nobody in the
Insurgency would notice, but it seemed they had.
I brushed off the accusation, made some
excuse about needing to go for an eye exam
and get contact lenses. But under the surface
were relentless shudders of panic. In hindsight,
the Gamma officer had told me this so
the Insurgency could see how I reacted,
but at the time, I didn’t realize…
and that played right into their hand.
The next day I was caught while going to send
an urgent SOS message to the O5 Council. Before
I could reach the place I stashed by encrypted
comm device, a group of Chaos Insurgency Beta
class operatives rushed me. I was bagged
again, pulled away kicking and screaming,
and unable to call for help…
Over the next few days, it was
like I’d been sent back in time to the start of my
infiltration. As the Insurgency tortured me again,
I refused to give in, despite how much I wanted
to just to make the pain stop. But even then,
it didn’t matter. Their knowledge of the
Foundation was greater than I realized,
and the Insurgents were easily able to crack the
encryption of my comm unit. With that broken, they
had access to all the messages I’d been sending
to the O5 Council; and realizing who had sent
me made them change their interrogation methods.
The Insurgents revealed something I hadn’t heard
before, something the Council had apparently
kept a secret. The Chaos Insurgency had once
been a part of the SCP Foundation. I refused
to believe it at first, but with all I’d seen
as an MTF agent, even my undercover mission, it
started to make sense. An off-the-record black
ops unit working for the O5 Council to circumvent
the Ethics Committee. They’d grown disillusioned
with how the Foundation handled its anomalies
and broken away to form… the Chaos Insurgency.
When I accepted that to be true, the
Insurgents brought me to what I had
been sent for. They took me to the Engine.
Now I’m awaiting my extraction transport. After
showing me the device that caused their earliest
founders to splinter off from the Foundation,
the Chaos Insurgency took me several miles
from their compound, to the co-ordinates the
O5 Council had told me to be at. The Foundation
think they’re getting their agent back,
and with me, plenty of intel on their enemies.
But the Engine showed me the truth. Showed me
the lies and fallacies of the Foundation,
and especially of the O5 Council. They
think they’re getting back their agent…
but I serve the Chaos Insurgency now.
Now go check out “SCP CHAOS INSURGENCY EXPLAINED”
and “I SURVIVED 100 DAYS HIDING FROM THE SCP
FOUNDATION... HERE’S WHAT HAPPENED” for
more mind-blowing centennial challenges!